alles klar
luca beantwortet sachen bei ask luca
beantwortet sachen bei luca beantwortet
ich kann noch immer keine ukulele
spielen
herzlich willkommen meine lieben freunde
ich habe mir angst gemacht und hab mir
gedacht wenn ihr fragen an mir ich hab
dann könnt ihr mir die stellen
wie funktioniert es denn jetzt hier
glaubst du siri kennt den clever bot sie
liebt ihn bruder mit welchen tierarten
hättest du bereit
alpakas alpakas alpakas ich habe sogar
so ein tolles bild angehangen wie kann
ich das denn jetzt kann ich irgendwo an
ich werde übrigens nur so behindert auf
die fragen eingehen also erwartet hier
keine produktive lebenshilfe oder von
siri versus clever wort alter das ist
eine schwierige frage von crafter
er gibt euch die besten antworten und
zwar das ist ohne spaß und ich fühle
mich wieder clever bot ihr könnt mir
fragen stellen und ich antworte dummen
ja cleverer 2.0 bin ich liebst du mich
eigentlich liebe ich nur mich läuft wie
kommt das schild rasen betreten verboten
mitten auf den rasen nicht wird sich wie
würdest du max und drei wörtern
beschreiben max11 beschreibung wie man
hier geben könnte
du bist toll alles klar danke ich weiß
was geht ab oder soll ich lieber fragen
was haften bleibt
wo geht die nächste reise hin in die
küche youtube deutschland in einem wort
als maul die sehr liebst du magst hab ne
fan fiction über euch geschrieben willst
du sie lesen dafür punkt 3 3 ich kann
nicht lesen kann noch nicht schreiben
mich vollidiot sn bei lesen vergessen
ich feiere deine videos so
schalke ist besser als hockey blog blog
wie kann ich immer blocken die kann ich
immer ein blogger die das hier hallo
herr auf einer skala von eins bis zehn
wie sehr liebst du mich - 17 alles klar
sonne ist in ordnung ich die tiere
gerade zu einem zebra also nicht wundern
falls ihr bei mir und alles und hey ich
bin luca ich ja ich bin wie stellst du
dir deine traumfrau vor
also eigentlich stelle ich mir so eine
traumfrau schon recht hübsch poisel
sonne sehr naturelle gibt zu du bist
schon ein bisschen in sie verliebt ihr
seid wie sherlock holmes aber ihr wisst
die ganze direkt was ich halt's maul
halten wolle wie so beantwortet zu
keiner meiner fragen
ich hab hunger wenn du nicht lesen
kannst du kannst du bitte gern
verwandten heiraten und martina denn
eigentlich
wir sind seit 1984 eigentlich in einer
glücklichen ehe haben 17 hunde und 34
kinder drei kühlschränke weil wir sind
immer wieder nur scheiße eigentliche was
was mache ich hier auch diese wissen so
hässlich hahahaha
ich kann mir beibringen wie man liest
soll halo berechtigen deinen account
nein niemals
bis bald diese natürlich bin ich
angemeldet ich beantworte fragen okay
was würdest du tun wenn du ein mädchen
auf einer brücke sehen würdest die kurz
davor zu springen alter ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass ihr mir solche ernsten
fragen stellen wenn wir mal zu diese
serie hier und auch die sachen die ich
hier beantwortet das ist alles nur spaß
das heißt wenn ich euch hdf schreibe
dann ist das spaß das ist ironie daraus
besteht bei kompletter kanal das heißt
nicht wenn ich jetzt hd app schreiben
würde dass ich möchte dass ihr mann von
der brücke springen das ist komplett
falsch und ich weiß genau dass wieder
ein so moralapostel in die kommentare
schreiben wir haben hey da sind leute
die machen sich da echt was raus wenn du
da was negative schreibst freunde nimmt
es mit humor ich bin zwar nicht witzig
aber nimmt es mit humor
wir machen weiter was ist momentan ein
lieblingslied david cent dort werden die
gerade viele fragen gestellt
die frage ist tatsächlich richtig geil
und zwar würdest du dir ein alpaka
kaufen wenn du genug platz hättest für
eine artgerechte haltung wie würdest du
es nennen
ich würde mir definitiv kaufen weil
alpakas sind so günstig ich würds
ballonen glaube ich also einfach magst
du mich ich mag mich du magst nicht
kennt das auch einer von euch von dieser
serie mit diesem pink grün wären
nein
ich würde gerne noch ein dritter
mittelfinger hoch holen aber ich habe
leider kein hast du einen lieblingsfilm
wenn ja welchen to girls one cup das ist
definitiv rating eleven out of tampa ich
hab lasagne ball so [ __ ] ich heiße
konkreter nicht konkret
bis mir richtig unser tipp direkt wieder
ganz viel freude gemacht
diese hier ist tatsächlich wieder eine
ganz heiße frage und zwar kommen bald
shirts mit diesem smiley aufgedruckt das
wäre so nach dem das mit dem nice mit
dem all das ist richtig stark eigentlich
nice bald kommen so nice t shirts mit
diesem leisten
was haltet ihr davon als ihr kennt ja
mal profilbild derzeit mit diesem
komischen zwei liegen nicht bei twitter
instagram und youtube und eigentlich
überall als profilbild habe hätte übels
box so shirt zu machen mit seiner tasche
hier dran irgendwie und dann ist ja die
dass miley drauf und einfach shirts mit
dem schmal die drauf oder irgendwie was
damit keine ahnung weil das wäre
eigentlich ich glaube das wäre cool oder
ein okay ganz mich in der nächsten video
größten nein nein nein marin hast du für
die zukunft irgendwelche pläne wenn ja
welche
ich möchte später tierärztin werden von
süßen kleinen kätzchen und zur freude
wir sind 125 minuten müssen für mich
wieder ein heidenspaß das ganze zu
schneiden nicht falsch ist oder kennst
du deinen klub selbst auf was finde
scheiß kommt ihr bitte nehmt diese serie
nicht all zu ernst ich will hier mit
keinem irgendwie schaden oder irgendwen
beleidigen aber ich finde es einfach
witzig wenn man dieses komplette ass
game mit diesen ganzen ich spirituellen
fragen wir so ein bisschen hoch nimmt
einfach das kennt ja selbst bei mir auf
dem kanal dass ich selber mich manchmal
selber und selber und selber selber
selber selber selber beleidiger deswegen
nehmt euch das nicht zu herzen wollt ihr
im zweiten teil hat euch gefallen
vielleicht geben auch alle einfach den
daumen runter ich fühle mich auf jeden
fall über eine bewertung freuen weil
viele leute nahmen dagegen
badenweiler denken nach der luca der
beleidigt nur seine fans was ja auch
eigentlich wirklich stimmt mir leid
wir sehen uns vielleicht wieder außer
ihr hasst mich jetzt schon blockiert